Oh
[Music]
hello welcome to lecture three of Gd 50
today we're gonna be talking about match
three shown by the little cubes here on
the slide cube match three originated a
little earlier than 2001 but the sort of
the first big game that came out that
was a sort of genre staple of match
three was bejeweled showing here on the
screen this is a more modern incarnation
of bejeweled but it came out originally
in 2001 is actually a web browser game
and the formula is very simple the
premise is you have a grid of different
colored or shaped items usually pretty
small like 8 by 8 or so and your goal is
just simply like the name says match
three or more of them in a row if you do
you get a certain number of points
matching usually more than three gives
you more points or a bonus and whenever
you match three the blocks will
disappear from the grid and they'll be
replaced by more grid more blocks and
the ones that you made holes for will
the blocks above them will come down
sort of via gravity this is a more
modern incarnation of the formula this
is candy crush which I think most people
know was a very big hit on mobile
devices and otherwise around 2013 2012
and that's probably the more most recent
big match three style game that's come
out but there are a lot of other takes
on it different versions that try to add
new features and stuff this is the sort
of game that we'll be putting together
today and I'll show you how and we'll be
covering a few other things as well so
the topics today I'll be covering first
of all a sort of fundamental concept in
dynamic languages a lot of dynamic
languages and also Lua that's called
anonymous functions which are functions
that are first-class meaning that they
operate as data types and so we can do
some fancy stuff with those tweening
which means just taking one thing and
sort of interpolating its value between
two values from one to a destination
value over time which is a very
important thing in games you can do
things like move objects we can also
tween their opacity just sort of
asynchronous behavior and asynchronous
sort of variable manipulation timers
very important we can time something to
happen at certain intervals or after a
certain length of time has passed to
sort of get us past the idea of storing
different timed variables or different
counter
in sort of break away and keep time or
objects they'll take care of this for us
we'll see how we do that with a specific
library and then we'll get into the
actual details of match-three and how to
solve matches and how to sort of account
for that fill in the grid account for
when we actually solve a match and
repopulate it once we've done so we'll
talk about how to do the do this
procedurally it's very simple compared
to I think breakouts sort of more
procedural layout system but it's still
randomization and talk about that and
then last if we have time we'll talk
about sprite arts and sprite art and
palettes which is a big sort of
fundamental thing when you're doing 2d
game development and something that this
and breakouts a sprite sheet took
advantage of was the idea of using on
purpose a restricted set of colors at
palette for creating your 2d art and are
a lot of really cool and impressive
things we can do with that but first I'd
like to actually show what we'll be
running today in class so I'm going to
come here into my directory make sure
I'm in the right place which I am so
this is part of the distribution code
which is online so there's a match-three
directory and would anybody like to come
demo it in class all right Ani come on
up alright so whenever you're ready go
ahead and just hit return here alright
and so this is my implementation of
match-three it uses a different set of
tiles we have things that are moving
over time it's actually it's a arrow key
based so so if you yeah this if you
press ENTER on any tile you can flip it
with another tile it doesn't have to be
a match in this case so you can
yeah it's a kind of got an unlucky board
there at the very bottom I see there's a
few some brown ones you can you can mesh
together so once you match them together
the tiles come down to repopulate you
get new tiles up top so notice we have a
timer on the left as well it's something
that's counting down we'll see how this
is actually done with a the library
we'll be using as opposed to sort of
managing a counter variable keeping
track of it over time yeah it's a lot of
games will actually implement it so you
have to you can only and this will be
part of the assignment actually where
you can only move a tile if it creates a
match in this case there's a and we can
see the timer sort of counting down and
then once you if you don't get past this
goal yeah there's a game over but thanks
I appreciate it so that's sort of the
game in a nutshell another thing I want
to point out too is this sort of like
the transition the circle the white
transitions and then the level text
those are all done with timers that
we'll be using in tweens which we'll be
covering in class here as some of our
early examples but there's a lot of
stuff that we sort of haven't touched on
but also a lot that we have it uses
sprites in a sprite sheet that and we've
done sort of that sort of thing before
we chopped up a sprite sheet and then
you know take out the whatever
individual quads you need and sort of
draw them to the screen here's what our
goal is which is you know we have a
title screen with match three start and
quit game in this case a little bit
simpler no high scores this time just
because we've already covered that but
we also have a level screen tells us
what level we're on before we can
actually play and there will be sort of
a transition box with text in it it'll
come down stop and then come down again
so sort of almost like chain behavior
which we'll see how we implement that
too and then lastly on the bottom there
is our sort of main game screen where we
have a level a score and then a goal if
you get the goal amount of points before
the timer runs out then you go to level
two and level three and level four and
the score increases by a multiplied
factor each time so the first thing I'd
like to start talking about today is how
we actually get timer behavior using
something a little bit more than just
you know keeping track of some variable
that we set to zero and then adding DT
to it every
every update there's a better way to do
that but first why don't we go ahead and
look at timer zero and so what I'm going
to do is go into the timer zero
directory I'm going to run it and we can
see here in the middle of the screen
just a very simple just a label that
just says timer and then X seconds where
you know that obviously the X is
incrementing over time every second so
serve Li like a crude way what would be
an easy way to implement this
yeah so the response was keep some
variable that you modify with DT in
update or display the variable yeah
that's definitely wait did you have some
yeah so keep a float variable but just
truncate the Delta time off of it you
could do that definitely we'll take a
look here at us to actually how I did do
it it's very very similar to that this
is the wrong directory though so it's in
timer zero in main so we do have a
variable so the current second here
which we are gonna keep track of zero
one two Lua doesn't really have the
notion of truncate a float because when
you take a number that's flowing point
and you make it into a string you
actually have to do string substitution
on it where you sort of like use a
function called G sub to take off the
last part manually because there doesn't
really differentiate between instant
floats it just has a number sort of data
type but we can do this by just keeping
track of whether or not we've passed a
certain length of time because we know
DT is given to us in seconds we can just
add to our variable and then every time
we've gone over one because it gives us
two it gives use like point zero
thirteen whatever one sixtieth or
approximately one sixtieth of a second
is once our timer we're gonna keep a
timer variable equals one we'll just
increment current second by one and then
we'll set that timer back to zero and
then we'll just repeat over and over
again will actually use modulus so they
in case we go slightly over one second
we can account for that we do that here
so second timer gets second timer plus
Delta time and then if it's greater than
one so if a full second has elapsed just
increment current second and then modulo
second timer by one Lua is a little
different in that most languages only
let u modulo something if it's an
integer but since there is no
differentiation you can actually modulo
floats and you'll get the floating point
value left over and so that has that's
the like the basic way of ax
doing that but there's a couple things
wrong with it so does anybody want to
suggest what is potentially bad or
unscalable about this kind of approach
well I'll show you timer one so we can
maybe get a sense of how this could kind
of get out of hand pretty quickly so
let's say first I'll run timer one so
let's go into timer one here and notice
so now we have five labels so we have
there they're running different
intervals so time or the first timer is
running it's incrementing every one
second the second timer is incrementing
every four seconds the third one is
incrementing every four seconds and then
so on three and then two so if we wanted
to do the same approach that we just did
this is what we would do we have five
variables five timers because we want to
keep track of whether or not something's
gone over more than just one second it's
not super easy to just put this all in a
table and iterate over it and use your
iteration logic to do that we actually
because they're in some sort of way at
random you know who knows what order you
know time or two takes two seconds okay
timer three takes four seconds timer for
takes three and then two you sort of
have to unmanageably keep all of this in
separate variables yes Tony
you could yeah in this case you could
again Lewis display it like it's a
little bit funky when you're you you
have to do like jisub and some weird
string stuff but yes you could do that
modulo one would still give you the
floating-point value because the mid
there's only one number type so if we
modulo to one point zero zero one five
seven by one we'd get zero point zero
zero one five seven yeah so yeah the it
was proposed that we've used modulo and
we could in short we could but what if
we're not just doing keep printing a
value to the screen what if we have like
10 different things like 10 different
creatures that are all doing different
things and we over time and we don't
know so I have to want to have to keep a
timer for each and every one of those
things in a simple example like this
yeah there's probably a on purpose it's
it's also a little bit convoluted just
to sort of illustrate the problem but
yes there there are shortcuts for this
but the fundamental problem is how can
we get rid of like having like five
different timers for something right so
and by the way I'll go to the next slide
timers zero the simple way timer one the
ugly way timer two is the clean way that
I found using this sort of ecosystem
there's a wonderful library and you
could implement this yourself the the
fundamental idea is have a global timer
object that then manages all of these
different things going on using the
power of what I alluded to earlier
anonymous functions and I'll show you
how that works
so in main.lua of time or two we have a
set of intervals we have a set of
counters
and then what we're doing here is we're
just saying 4i gets one to five we're
calling a function called timer dot
every so if you're familiar with
JavaScript programming there's like a
set interval function which lets you do
something every length of time so this
timer so first of all timers just a
library we've just required it here it's
part of the knife ecosystem and then
here we have a couple functions timer
dot every and timer after that will that
will use well basically what it does is
you give it a length of time timer dot
every seconds it's in seconds and you
can give it fractional seconds you're
passing in just a function here just an
anonymous function does I'm a name but
because Lua and a lot of dynamic
languages treat functions as first-class
citizens as it's called because they are
data types you can just pass them into
functions and this is simply this allows
us to do behavior like this that we
would I would otherwise be a little bit
tricky to do we can just say after this
block of time if assuming we've built
some structure that is probably just
storing a table with a bunch of things
that have like a length of time in them
just call this block of code later it's
called a callback function we're just
gonna call it back and then we're gonna
do this we're gonna say counters i gets
counters i plus one so we've had we have
all of these intervals and all of these
counters so it'll just basically manage
that for us and now we don't have five
variables we don't have I mean you do
have to set your whatever your intervals
whatever you want those to be that's
your that's your primitive at this point
you just need the length the lengths of
time depending on your problem in this
case that's all we need you might need
more than that if depending on what you
want to do with timer but in this case
we just want to increment some value
over time so keep counters and then just
keep track of the intervals and then our
codes gone from I don't know how many
lines it was a lot larger than was 96
lines down to 98 lines down to 70 and
this is incredibly scalable now we just
if we wanted to add another one it's
like eight for example we just need to
add eight and then that oh I guess we'd
have to
I'd have to do this as well I guess five
just six and then I'm on a computer that
requires me to off my user so I can make
changes or just real quickly see if I
didn't mess up and so yeah basically
we're deferring everything to timer now
we get the exact same behavior but ass
much smaller length of code and the nice
thing is it's very declarative we can
just say okay every the something
seconds I want this chunk of behavior to
happen I don't have to see okay I've got
like timers a periodic counters here
okay down in my draw function okay go to
all these it's it's iterative and it's
declarative and that's sort of like the
ultimate goal in here at the very bottom
it did actually work now it's working
every eight seconds which is nice one
two there we go
super easy to extend we're gonna be
using it a lot in this problem set and
also in future lectures just because
it's a lot easier than keeping track of
a bunch of counter variables and there's
another one another function that we're
seeing here timer after because
sometimes you just want to wait a
certain length of time like maybe you
have every one second for five seconds
you want to bomb to tick and then after
five seconds you want to blow up and you
could also model that with another
function that we'll see soon but these
are probably the two core like
time-based functions and you can go here
to this URL to see the knife library
there's a bunch of modules that are
really nice we just happen to be using
timer and it's tween and every after
functions primarily in this problem but
we'll use another one called event in
the zelda pset where we actually look at
like how to dispatch events and like
triggers and stuff and to prevent us
from like checking every frame Oh what
do we have to do like if some wall is
broken this frame then do this we can
just dispatch in the event that we blow
up a wall we'll get to that any
questions at all about how like that
model this two models sort of differ and
like how they work
okay cool so the next sort of thing I
want to look at so we can tie that back
into also real quick if we want match
three whoops and then there's a timer
that's manipulating the text on the
screen the all of those letters in the
this is in the start state of the game
code all those letters have a color
associated with them but they're on a
timer so that after every point zero
seven five seconds they'll go to another
color and to another color and so we
don't have to keep track of every
letters individual color and a timer for
it we can just change them all if we
start the game something else is on a
timer the timer actually there which is
just decrementing some value every
one-second decrement timer by one and
that's it and we don't have to keep any
we don't have to say anything more than
just that and that's what's really nice
about using that kind of model so
another thing that you probably also
noticed and I'll run it again is this
fade out and fade in and also that
animation those are things that are
happening over time we don't actually we
I mean we can just sort of manipulate
them we can keep track of some sort of
counter for it we can also just say over
this length of time change this value to
this value and that's a much easier way
to model the problem mentally and so
we'll illustrate that first I'm going to
go to tween 0 so tween 0 is the simple
way to do something so I'm going to
illustrate tweening here with flappy
bird just going left to right so up
there that's what happens when you print
out the timer the number by the way just
by default and so if you wanted to let's
sort of truncate it yeah you could just
jisub the first two I guess depending on
how large it is and that would have the
effect of displaying it as just an
integer but we can see that over two
seconds we've had and there's a little
bit of overlap just because Delta time
can go a little bit over two seconds
when you're adding to it because it just
adds whatever length of time as a float
has a lap since the last frame in this
case we're just adding it until it's
greater than or equal to two so in this
case we went point zero one over to by
the time
actually ended some iterations will be
less than that so this one will be yeah
see that one was less than two point
zero one it just depends on your
computer in your specs but flappy bird
starts on the very left so he's got an
x-coordinate and then at the very end
he's got another x-coordinate so the
simple solution is what we can take sort
of we know that we want this to elapse
over two seconds
so we can do is I'm going to pull up
between zero in move duration here it's
a constant two seconds just for the sake
of this example sprite here just a
simple image I'm putting everything in
sort of one code file this time as
opposed to sort of breaking it out into
subclasses just for simplicity because
these are such small examples but we're
setting its x and y OU and this is
another lua trick by the way you can
assign two values to to two variables to
two values using a comma here so floppy
X comma floppy Y gets zero and then
virtual height divided by two minus
eight setting us X to zero we have a
timer here and then its end X so we want
it to end at the end of the screen so
we're gonna say virtual with - his width
and then the usual boilerplate for
getting a project set to go if it's less
than the move duration
so if timer is you know 0 going up to -
but it's not quite - yet we're gonna add
DT to it and then we're going to
basically assign it to either the the
lowest of end X so it'll no it'll never
go higher than end X or end X times the
ratio of timer over move duration so
timer over move duration if it's less
than - that's going to be some value
some fractional amount less than 1 so
it's going to basically just scale it
depending on how far we've moved the
timer between 0 and 2 so just a scaling
operation this will this happens to only
work in the context of moving something
from left to right or from 0
to something else but it's a crude basic
way of illustrating like a very basic
tween operation that's what it is it's a
multiplier of some ratio of how much
time has passed versus how much time
we're actually looking to elapse and
that has the effect once again of just
you know it's scaling the ratio because
it's you know it's timer over move
duration it's something over two but
it's not quite 2 over 2 until it gets 2
over 2 and it's 1 then end x times 1 is
going to be end X but before that it's
going to be some fraction of end X
between 0 and end X so it has the effect
of giving us a very basic tween but it's
a little bit you know we have a little
bit to manage here it doesn't it's not
what doesn't really feel super clean do
you guys have any questions about how
this works ok so we're gonna go here so
first of all any like thoughts about how
that might not be super scalable looking
back at like the last example
yeah and what if your index is different
for every single one then you have a
kind of a mess right like what if we had
something like this like it's not like
you don't want to keep track of a you
know an end X I mean they all happened
to have the end the same index but notes
they're moving at different rates
they're all moving at some sort of
random amount there's a thousand we
could I mean we could we could go
crazier if we wanted we could this is a
fun thing to do is a stress testing so
if I go to tween one and I go to main
timer max is ten so we're saying the the
longest possible time any bird can take
to get from left to right it's gonna be
ten seconds so right here we're we're
using a table based approach here we're
actually keeping track of a thousand
Birds and we're saying okay here's an
empty table from one to a thousand added
a new bird and in this case we're not
adding a bird object or anything it's
just a table they'll start x equals zero
left side there Y is random so they can
be anywhere between the top and the
bottom of the screen so over time is 24
24 happens to be the height of the
sprite and I should have probably put
flappy sprite get height right there and
then rate they're all gonna have their
own rate so rate gets math dot random
math dot random without a value passed
into it gives you a fractional value
between 0 and 0.99 0.99 and and a nine
what this has the effect of doing is
math dot random with just two values if
you pass in like ten and fifty it's
gonna give you ten 250 but they're
always going to be integer values you
can't say like ten point oh and fifty
point oh and assume that it'll know what
you're talking about it's just going to
be integers so if you give it one value
it'll know okay you're asking me for a
float between zero and point nine and a
nine that's gonna act as the fractional
part of whatever value we might want to
generate using a math dot random with a
value passed in so here we're saying
okay
math are random timer max minus 1 so
timer max is nine so our timer max is 10
sorry so if we subtract one from that
this is math dot random 10 so we're
gonna get a value between 1 & 9 so time
room X minus 1 is 9 sorry if I said 10
time X is 10 times X minus 1 is 9 but
we're adding math.random some fractional
amount so whatever value we choose
between 1 actually between yeah between
1 & 9 it's going to be that value point
something so this is how you get random
basically at the end of the day this I
get random floating point numbers in Lua
and love 2d does that make sense
any other questions about their final
rate is going to be anywhere from 1 in
this case from 1 to a nine point nine
and a nine if we want it to be zero we
could do that and that'll give us the
effect of taking whatever we get and
make and subtracting one so now it'll be
it'll be between zero and eight point
nine and a nine and if we did this
no because math are random if you pass
in a value it'll always do from one to
some value yeah the question was will
will math our random give you zero if
you pass in a value and math at random
by default gives you between 1 and
something else and so that's why we do
this also that's not why we do this we
do this to add the fractional part so
that we can get fractional floats
between some value but yeah if you
wanted it to be between 0 and something
else you just subtract 1 from the final
result because we know that we're always
going to get from 1 to some value if you
- from 1 you will never go below 0 it'll
always be 0 to something else and then
in that case we probably would just take
off the minus 1 from time Ermac so that
it would be between zero and nine point
nine and and and nine in this case but
as a design decision I made it so that
we always have at least a rate of 1
because then it could get really really
slow if it's like zero point zero zero
so 5 or something like that I wouldn't
want that no take ages
and then okay so here we have a we have
a timer we're not using knife timer in
this case yet but as long basically in
update we're just saying as long as
timer max is less than a timer is less
than timer max so this will this update
logic will only run as long as we
haven't like on over timer max increment
it and then for each bird basically
we're doing the same thing that we did
before except we're using that Birds
rate as the scale factor yeah the sort
of the denominator of that ratio and
that'll have the effect of multiplying
all of those birds individually based on
their own rate rather than some like
global rate if that makes sense
and then here we're just drawing all of
them at their own X&Y and just again
we're de storing birds are just a table
with a few variables in this case just a
very simple shell and it has the effect
of oh and one thing I wanted to do is
just add a zero there I got a safe do
this every time because I didn't set my
permissions appropriately but now is
gonna be ten thousand Birds so let's see
how this looks so it looks pretty
similar actually but it's a little more
condensed now I don't notice a framerate
drop if we wanted we could go down to
love dot draw and like a love dog
graphics up printf fps and then to
string love dot timer dot get fps and
then let's set it to 4 and then virtual
height minus 16 and then gotta do this
again this should have the effect of
giving us our frame rate so we can
really stress test this and see what the
oh I made a mistake okay let's see what
did I do
push that star I missed uh I'm guessing
I missed a I missed a
Oh do that and then that and then save
it again sorry about that don't be too
many of these edits but I figured this
would be fun to illustrate so now this
should work right Oh printf so we have
that oh right and then what just needs
to be print doesn't need to be printf
sorry this will be worth it
I hope there we go
51 60 okay it takes a couple seconds has
to interpolate between the last couple
times that it's pulled four frames and
when you start up it doesn't have the
data it needs so ten thousand easy let's
do like a million so we have ten
thousand a hundred thousand million I
really got to change those permissions
didn't get a practicing my password
though I'm gonna go ahead and do that
oof
Oh my laptop is suffering oh man but
they're all moving independent of
framerate this is just a testament to
how powerful Delta time is they all move
there after ten seconds I mean we got to
like ten point six seconds which is not
good that means that's how long passed
between the last frame but my laptop
cooler cannot handle a million birds on
the screen but it can handle like 10,000
or maybe even a hundred thousand and
that's just a fun way like a fun thing
to do in general when you want a sort of
stress test your game is just like put
the frames per second on and just like
go nuts just like add a lot of stuff
just see what your computer is capable
of because you can sort of find new fun
things that way I guess and maybe like
just see how good your code is - yeah
between between zero simple way we have
you know just variables and like one
counter no tables or anything between
two is a good way for if we have a lot
of things that we want to manipulate
over time but like what if now we want
some of them to like change their
opacity over time or something
it starts to get a little bit more
complicated right and this is by the way
I should have put this earlier in the
code but this is the sort of like the
knife library is responsible for timer
and a lot of other things that we'll be
looking at it's got a bunch of modules
here listed behavior for state machines
which is sort of like what we've been
doing for state machines but they have
their own version of it
next up bind so you can pre bind
arguments to functions and create like
functions like sub function it's called
currying but create sub functions of
other functions that have predetermined
variables knife dot chain we'll see
actually how that can be used
coming up later convoke is for
co-routines will see co-routines in the
context of unity but basically they're
functions that can pause their state for
later nice tie event will use in two
weeks for zelda maybe even next week if
I can fit it in for Mario memo eyes is
for memoization which is like a func
it's like a dynamic programming related
thing serialized system system is going
to be useful to know about in context of
unity as well unity uses an entity
component system for much of its
structure and I've got test and then
lastly knife timer which is what we'll
end up using and this is probably my
favorite sort of library that exists in
the loved 2d ecosystem and so with that
said we'll look at tween to now I'm
gonna go here into tween too and so now
we have not just movement but also their
opacity like they all start at different
opacity levels and we want to not only
change their movement over time but also
the opacity right so it would get a
little bit trickier if we decided to do
it with a current situation totally
doable but like how how would we go
about changing just right now their
opacity just as is how do you change a
sprites opacity
is it a variable he said it more time
I love doubt response was the love dog
graphics draw so it's actually not an
argument to that function it's a so I'll
show you now so in order to draw
something at some different opacity it's
actually loved art graphics offset color
and we do that here so recall that love
2d is a state machine and how it draws
things and so you can draw you can
basically set a color onto anything that
you draw whether it's a font an image or
a shape and if you just pass in 255 255
255 that's white and then if you give it
an opacity which is the fourth parameter
which is the Alpha sort of component of
that then that's how transparent it will
be and so we could we could have done
this with other colors too we could have
done this with like if I wanted to tint
it red and also have it be like sort of
transparent we could do that if we just
did to 5500 Bertot opacity but if you
just want to manipulate opacity
independent of or it's transparency or
its alpha independent of its color and
keep it the same exact color you just do
it white if you did it black nothing
would show up actually is that is that
true actually I mean let me verify that
pretty sure that's right but
I could be wrong
I'm right thankfully okay
that or they're just black and there's a
black background too
so yeah you have a question time okay so
we'll take it on faith that that is
correct and back to the sort of the gist
of this example we have timer max again
actually we really haven't changed much
what we have changed is we still have
our Birds right they need to keep we
need to keep track of their X of their Y
of their rate well not necessarily their
rate oh well there right yeah because
we're actually gonna loop over each of
these and then create a timer between
operation for them and their opacity oh
right they start with an opacity of zero
and fate of 255 regardless of their
regardless of their like they they do it
over the they basically their opacity
changes at the same rate as their X dot
or their as their X does so the farther
away the longer they take the slower
they say to fully opaque and we see this
here so fork a bird and pairs of birds
so for every bird we're just gonna set a
tween and then this is tween so time our
top tween is I think I have a slide on
it here right a super cool useful
function super easy to use - it takes a
duration just like timer dot every timer
dot after and it takes a definition so
in this case it doesn't take an
anonymous function like the other ones
did because we're not really saying I
want to do some sort of like undefined
behavior over the course of this
operation what I want to do is just
change some values I want to interpolate
them so what we're gonna do is just pass
in a this is the syntax for it we pass
in square brackets the actual thing that
we want to change in this case I want to
change bird I want bird to change in
some way and then what I want its values
to change toward are these I want its X
to change to end X and I want soap asset
e to go to 255
and I wanted to do it over bird rate and
so this bird rate every bird story and
so for birds had got a rate of two then
it's X is gonna go to index at over the
course of two seconds and so pasady is
gonna go to 255 over the course of two
seconds and you can put as many things
as you want and as many like you can put
as many variables here and as many
entities entities being anything that
you want to change that has a field any
like table based or class based
structure you can pass any of those in
here and just sort of between them all
at the same if they all have the same
rate and then just sort of get that
operation that way and so that has the
effect here of all we need to do is just
add like it's like two lines of code but
now it's easily like changed it so that
we can just between two things at once
and that's the power of timer dot tween
and we'll see that so back to actually
match three if we want to like look at
that again like this is a tween
that's a tween that's a tween and that's
a tween so like the white the the sort
of the foreground there it's just a
rectangle that fills the whole screen is
a white rectangle but we're like I have
it set to like timer dot tween opacity
from zero to 255 before that gets called
if we like go from the start to the
begin game state and then if we go from
like the like at the beginning of the
beginning get a game state before the
like the level text comes down it's a
going from 255 to zero so it's just the
reverse of that just a tween and then
all the all it's doing is just drawing a
rectangle to the screen but that's how
you get a sort of like a very simple
transition same thing for fade to black
if you want to fade the whole screen to
black just draw a rectangle the size of
the screen and then just between its
opacity from 0 to 255 and then vice
versa
and that's how you get simple transition
could be any color you want to be a red
transition and then the the like the
level text that's just a tween on the Y
right and then I just have some
rectangle loved-up graphic start
rectangle with text and it just says
timer tween to like virtual height
divided by 2
- 8 and then timer dot after one so I
could we can actually pull this up if we
want we can see how this works
today's gonna be a little lighter on
like the the main distro code just
because a lot of this is kind of more
conceptual but in the begin game state
we'll actually in the start state is
when we go so these Cutlass colors and
letter table and stuff that's all for
like the match three texts if you're
curious so like these are all back to
what I said earlier about the the
beginning screen having like match three
with the different colors going on a
timer these are just tables of colors so
notice that like this just RGB a and
then I'm just performing a shuffle on
them every point is 0 7 5 seconds so one
will - will get one and vice-versa it
will all go down and then six will come
up here - one every you know 0 7 5
seconds and then M gets mapped to this
one it gets mapped to this one T - this
one ch3 and that's it that's done here
and line 44 of the start state but what
I was going to show you was the between
for the transition so here in start
state in the update function if we press
ENTER and our current menu item is 1
meaning that we were on start game not
quit game just timer tween here and
notice that we have a finish function
which will show I'm actually gonna show
you in the next couple examples the
chain examples but finish is just a
function that you can run after any
timer that just says hey when this is
finished run this block of code and
notice that takes an anonymous function
here just like that so we can say okay
tween over the course of one second
those for passing self into here because
we want to manipulate ourselves we have
a value that we want to manipulate so
self dot transition alpha
so we're saying I want to take my
transition alpha and I want it to go to
255 and we set it to 0 by default so at
the very top here
at line 60 transition alpha is just our
white rectangle that fills the screen
I'm just saying
set to zero so that we don't see it at
all it's gonna be invisible it's still
there no matter what it's hidden but
after we press Enter tween it to 255
over the course of one second and then
when that's finished notice this is
familiar right G state machine change
begin game we're gonna go to the game
state the begin game state after that
we're passing a level gets 1 we're
starting the game and then we're gonna
remove this color remove that timer from
the it is actually unnecessary in this
circumstance but you can remove timers
from timer like if you have something
going constantly in this case the color
timer and let's say we move from this
state to the next state the next state
doesn't have all those colors right so
the match three colors so we don't need
to keep because timers a global object
it's gonna keep updating over and over
again we don't need we don't need
certain timers to exist indefinitely we
can just remove this one because it's
not relevant anymore but this is all it
takes just to give us a simple like
transition from one screen to another
just give this transition alpha 255 down
in the actual render function where is
it it is right here so right here
draw our transition rect it's gonna be
drawn last so that it draws over
everything when we finally do get a
transition but self that transition
alpha and that's all we really need we
just need the we need to keep the
variable and then whenever we want to
perform like some sort of operation over
time just use timer dot tween it's that
easy but that was a little bit of I mean
as a relevant tangent we would have
talked about it anyway but that's how
that's so the first sort of use case
that I think of in this project and then
also the the label I'll show you the
label a little bit but I think before we
do that let's talk about chaining so you
guys have probably played a lot of games
where like maybe there's a cutscene and
you're looking at a character and
they're like they're walk and then maybe
they turn and they walk another
direction and they walk up and then they
like speak to you there's like a dialog
box
and then maybe they do like an animation
or something and then maybe some other
things happen that are like on some sort
of predestined path it's a very like
discrete path it's not random its laid
out in advance it's a series of steps
one consecutive that's sort of that's
the concept of chaining things together
is relevant when we get to sort of
timing things because when we finish
timing something because usually a lot
of those things happen like over the
course of time right like over the
course of like five seconds NPC one will
walk up north and then they'll turn left
and then they'll say something we want
to like we want to model that we don't
want to basically have variables that
say if NPC one is at this tile then do
this if NPC dialogue open then do this
then you know wait for key we just want
to we basically want to say walk here do
this do this do this in like a flat sort
of like easy or at least semi flat easy
sink what's a sequence of steps and I
have a few examples to illustrate how we
can do that using timer for some semi
basic use cases so chain zero is the
first one so this one is just flappy
bird he's going left to right and he
goes down then he goes back left again
and then he goes up so like what's the
what's there like the basic way that we
model this that we implement this just
off the cuff
we would we would in an idea we would if
we didn't know about finish how would we
how would we probably do it I shouldn't
have given away finish before before I
got to that example I kind of got ahead
of myself but like somebody we can we
can imagine somebody maybe saying okay I
want flappy to move left to right right
to bottom bottom to left down bottom to
up maybe they have maybe they're gonna
say if flappy is like less than or like
has reached first point move left and
else if he's reached bottom or point to
move down and then move left move up and
in those Kate both of those cases he's
you know they're sort of implore
changing the x and y value of flappy and
it's basically just a lot of like ifs
and like state variables it's like you
see I see it in a surprising amount of
code just like state being kept all over
the place the first implementation of
that that will look at uses something
similar so in Chains zero and there's
only two examples here actually for
chain but chain zero there's a movement
time and then a timer we're gonna like
it be semi clean about it we have some
destinations we have okay so we have
like destination one like I know that I
don't necessarily want to like keep
track of a bunch of maybe a bunch of if
statements but you know I'm going for
like assuming that I don't know what
timer can do for us here I'm just saying
okay I want his first destination to be
virtual with minus his width and then
keep him at y 0 so right edge of the
screen assuming that he starts at 0 0
and then I want his second destination
to be that same side on the x-axis but I
want it the Y to be virtual height minus
his height so go to the bottom of the
screen then I want it to be 0 and his
height from the bottom of the screen and
then 0 back to 0 0 so we have those
modeled and then I want to keep a flag
in each of those I want to I want to
know whether he's reached that state yet
so I'm gonna go I'm gonna iterate over
that table I just created and just add a
new key to each of these called
just said to false just by default he
hasn't reached all of them yet and then
in the update basically I'm gonna set
timer to the min of movement time so
it'll never go higher than movement time
and then timer plus Delta time and then
for every destination in destinations if
it wasn't reached then set its x and y
flappy' x sleppy Y which are in this
case we're uncleanly using global
variables to sort of keep track of this
flappy X flappy Y gets base X so notice
another problem we have to maintain
where we are relative to our next spot
in order for this math to work because
we before we just took his flappy birds
basically the the timer divided by
movement time was a ratio where we
scaled the end destination and assign
that to flappy which had the effect of
you know moving flappy left to right but
if we do that in the opposite right to
left it's the math isn't the same
because he's going he's going backwards
he is getting negative values added to
his to his X value so we need to keep
track of a base that he started at for
each of these operations base X base Y
so at the very beginning base X base Y
is zero zero so it's actually gonna be
much the same but as soon as flappy gets
the right edge of the screen we want
base X to be the right edge of the
screen base y still zero and then if he
goes down we want base-wide to then be
bottom edge of the screen base X to be
right edge and so forth so what we do is
we just scale we're still using a timer
over movement time as our scale factor
but we're adding our the difference of
our destination and our base and we're
multiplying by that scale factor instead
and so this difference if we add it
whether we're moving left or right or
down or or up it's going to have the
effect of filling in that gap of
bridging that no matter where we are no
matter which direction we want to go and
so this is this is basically a fairly
complete linear interpolation algorithm
which is the basis of tweening just
interpolate some value between another
value in the case of it's usually
modeled in geometry as of the line
between two segments and then if timer
gets movement time we've reached our
destination
reset the timer reset our base X&Y and
that has the effect of just doing what
we saw earlier which is just putting
them directly so any questions as to how
this sort of interpolation how this way
of modeling the problem works all right
so there is a better way a much better
way thanks to finish timer da finish
which you can which you can apply to any
timer operation including timer tween so
we can basically say okay once that
operation is finished do something and
this is all we have to do we just have
to say timer dot tween we no longer have
to interpolate at all that's taken care
of for us by timer so we're doing timer
dot tween over movement time flappy set
it to this was before we add all this in
a destinations table with reached flags
as well now we just have the X&Y
here just X so on the first movement we
want his X to be right edge of the
screen just like before y get zero once
that's finished anonymous function with
another timer dot tween so we're saying
okay once you're finished then tween him
from the right edge top right edge to
the bottom right edge so why cuz virtual
height - flappy sprite get height and
then once that's finished another
anonymous function another timer dot
tween another finish another anonymous
function another timer dot tween and
this is in its own way unscalable it's
nested it's called
there's a term for it called callback
hell because you just get infinite sort
of like downward-sloping anonymous
functions with all this behavior there
are ways to flatten it and
we potentially will talk about it it's
part of knife chain.i thought chain as a
way to turn all of these basically and
basically it would look something like
this would be like chain and they would
be like move flappy XY move flappy X to
Y it wouldn't be X to Y to it would
actually we'd actually write these out
here but it would have the exact same
effect and that that's this is sort of
like a if you're looking to maybe
implement like a cutscene system or like
just some sort of scripting system for
your game that's very declarative
and sort of imperative and style like
this is sort of like this is like the
holy grail of like chain of like
chaining behavior and getting it to work
and just like making it look nice and
readable yeah
yes you could do that too the response
was you could pass in a table - you
could iterate over a table and within
that table generate a timer dot tween
the only sort of issue comes about with
finish and there is a way I guess
because I guess you could get a
reference back to the timer and then add
a finish block to it but then you would
sort of lose out on I mean that it that
does work for yes for like the same
function if it's the same like if all
you're doing is moving something to a
bunch of locations that's absolutely
true but if we wanted like flappy say
something and Hiro like disappear and
then the hero flash maybe it gets a
little bit trickier to do stuff like
that but yes I agree there are ways of
modeling the this particular example is
a little bit repetitive and could be
modeled I think better with a function
that takes advantage of the fact that
timers can be returned and then given
new function finish variables I have to
experiment with it to see because I'm
actually not a hundred percent sure that
you can add a finish now I think you can
actually I think you can add a finish
function to a reference because just a
function on an object so yeah but in the
independent of that I think the goal
probably is one knowing how we can now
chain behavior and then to sort of
striving towards flattening it but in
the purpose of this problem set we'll
see this a couple of times and it mean
it's just world's better than before I
think what's the 76 lines and then tween
1 or chain 0 was 96
ok so 20 lines of code I mean yeah and
also the fact that now we have a
declarative interface for modeling
asynchronous behavior like that's really
the fundamental thing is not having like
some value that models your duration or
your counter or whatever
value but just saying hey over this
length of time I want you to do this I
want you to do this I want you to do
this I want you to this after this
length of time I want you to do this and
yeah so I think it's that that I always
like to try and strive towards like
making code as declarative as possible
just so that you can read it in the
future and then like you're you know the
people working on your code base can
also read it well in the future and I
think timer does a pretty awesome job of
that and this is a just a reference for
timer finish so it just takes a callback
and then once a timer function tween
every or after has completed it triggers
that callback so we're gonna take a
break for like five minutes now and then
once we get back we'll talk about
swapping and some of the algorithms we
use in match 3 starting with just
rendering a board getting tiles to swap
tweening them and then we'll actually
look at how we take falling tiles and
account for them and then repopulate
them but yeah all right we're back
so recall before break we were looking
at timer instead of how to take code
that was previously managed by timers
and kind of asynchronous but also very
stateful and sort of messy and all over
the place and putting it into a more
declarative clean easy to express format
via timer tween timer dot every time
after time or finish time or colon
finish for any timer objects so with all
that other way now we'll start talking
about the actual match-three mechanics
and the very first thing that we'll look
at is swap 0 and this is the spritesheet
for match 3 that's included in the
distro so as we can see it's a something
that we can easily chop up with generate
quads as we saw before just a function
provided in utila WA these are all 32 by
32 pixels so it very very easy just to
go through all of them and just you know
basically just generate quads with the
spritesheet 32 32 and just get a table
with all of these individual things but
notice that they're sort of blocked up
into you know patterns of colors right
and this has actual meaning and value
for our game because when something is
the same color and only when something
is the same color a tile is the same
code
are we allowed to trigger a match with
it if we get any three or four anything
higher than three together in a line
vertically or horizontally that's a
match and we need to remove it from the
table so we need some sort of way of
identifying these tiles as being of some
color and then they also happen to have
a different pattern on them this one's
got nothing but then an X and then a
circle and a square so those patterns
it's not implemented in the distro but
part of the assignments actually gonna
be make them relevant but the part that
is implemented is the actual matching of
the colors and so the first thing that
we'll need to do probably when we
actually get into the core code of the
distribution is instead of just you know
putting them into one table sort of
categorizing them splitting it up into
maybe one two three four five six seven
eight nine times two eighteen tables so
we can just say like gee frames at color
so color being one two 18 and then get
the index into that so there's six
within each one so it'll be one two six
one two six will be the variety with one
being the base variety and part of the
assignment will be make sure that the
base variety is the only one that we
start with on level one but then
gradually introduce these other
varieties and you can sort of put them
in whatever hierarchy you want to but
make them have some sort of value later
on on top of a few other things the
assignment will cover but that's the
sprite sheet in a nutshell and we'll be
splitting it that way so eighteen kua
eighteen tables of quads instead of one
quad of whatever this amount is 8 by 16
not sure how many that is off the top of
my head but let's take a look at swap 0
in the distribution so we can sort of
get a sense of what we need to do to
begin implementing our match 3 game
notice we have require util for generate
quads we're just gonna generate for this
basic example we're not going to
differentiate between colors and
varieties or anything we're just going
to put them all into one quad or one
table of quads so we're just going to
use regular generate quads function
we're not going to differentiate them
we're just going to use our sprite here
our match 3
PNG provided in the distro which is the
exact same image that we just saw on the
screen I'm going to just generate them
they're 32 by 32 by generate the quads
for them they're 32 by 32 pixels I'm
assigning it but to a table here called
tile quads and then here we're calling
generate board and so generate board
isn't all that dissimilar to what we saw
before with maybe the level maker in
breakout where we just spawn a bunch of
bricks or a bunch of tiles in this case
except in this case they're kept in a
nice 2d array that's always going to be
8 by 8 if that's never going to change
just by the sort of like one of the
constraints of the game mesh 3
traditionally is an 8x8 grid that's
always full of tiles of some variety so
local tiles it's going to be an empty
table and then we're just going to do a
nested for loop here y 2x the standard
is usually Y first and then X and then
we index Y before X just because the
individual rows of the like in a 2d
array or sprite or table will be such
that for example if our table was equal
to this I'm sorry
syntax bug if we did this and then we
have a table here and a table here a
table here and we had like 0 1 1 1 1 1 1
1 and then 1 1 1 1 if we index into this
table so table at 0 that's going to give
us another table right that's not going
to give us a that if like let's say we
wanted to go like we wanted to get the
court the value at table 2 3 the
instinct might be to think okay I'm an
index at X Y just because X Y tends to
be more commonly seen but if we did that
and assumed that X was horizontal and Y
is vertical in this arrangement which is
how we have it then table 2
wouldn't be this value here Table two
would be this table here the first value
you pass into indexing some table is
when it's a nested table is just in fact
the table itself which is why we
actually need to do when we want to get
some value we have to index at table Y X
so it's all its flipped for that reason
because X is actually going to be the
further the first index is going to be
these sort of sub tables or sub arrays
if you're in like C or Java or something
like that
so when you see table Y X and you're
wondering why it's not table X Y that's
the reason so any questions as to why
that is or how that works yeah in this
case yeah I was I was using zero-based
indexing but Lua is one index that was
just habit
but yeah Lua I was pointed out that I
was using zero-based indexing in my
example you want to use one based
indexing when you're actually
programming and not zero based but same
principle applies it would be 0 would be
1 in that case in a general-purpose
language in or in a most languages where
we if we were to abstract a problem out
0 and I can see aniseed 2d array or C++
or Java 0 would be appropriate there but
anyways we have a nested for loop so why
we're starting out why and then we're
going to X and then basically that has
the effect of you know Y and then X X X
X Y X X X X just insert a blank table
fill it with we're just using tables
here so we're not using any sort of tile
class or bored class or anything fancy
we're just using raw data types here so
we're just saying insert into tiles Y
which by the way if we're at
x equals 1/8 here and we're in any given
iteration of our outer Y loop tiles Y
will be the last table that we just
inserted the last blank table on the
first iteration of this X loop but so
basically it's saying in the inner table
that I just put into the board the this
sort of table that's going to represent
our board the tiles table insert a new
table so the so we have a table of
tables of tables the third table are the
actual tiles themselves you can sort of
think of this table as being a tile data
type more or less just implemented using
a table that has an x coordinate a y
coordinate and then a tile and the tile
is going to be a random number that's
going to be the index into our quads so
each tile holds its X&Y
and then notice that we're multiplying
by 32 because we're going to use this to
draw the tile and the tiles are 32
pixels tall by high or sorry wide by
tall we are going to multiply X minus 1
recall because even though tables are 1
indexed coordinates are 0 indexed so X
gets that times 32 why except I'm sorry
2 and then get a random number between 1
and the number of quads in our tile
quads table so recall this number sign
here is just a shorthand for length of
the table and then we're gonna return it
so we generated our board it's it said Y
by X grid of little tables of table rows
of little tables that all have an X Y
and a tile ID and the tile ID maps to
the quads that we just generated if we
go up to okay that's that's it for the
init function the load sorry love that
load in this in this example the love
draw uses a function called draw board
and we pass in 128 by 16 the 128 by 16
is just XY offsets we're just gonna draw
our board at 128 16 and this is gonna
Center our board and then if we go down
to draw board at line 89 gets an offset
X offset Y next
for loop again we're just iterating back
over the tiles that we got and recall
actually generate board returns tiles
and then we set board equal to the
result of generate board so down here in
line 89 again in draw board actually a
line 95 within this nested for loop
we're going to get a tile at board YX
just so we have a shorthand reference
for it we don't have to say board YX
several times which you would have to
here we're just gonna draw the sprite
the quad at tile tile tile tile which
recall is a random number between 1 and
whatever the number of quads we have in
our tile quads table and then that X
plus offset X and the y plus the offset
Y which has the effect of drawing every
single tile in our grid at some given
offset and that has the result and I
probably should have run this actually
in advance just so I could illustrate it
whoops see these zero but we have a
simple board looks nice it's colorful
but it's very very basic just a 2d sort
of render of our game there's no
behavior anything just just how we draw
the board so any questions as to how
just the drawing and the creation of the
board sort of work okay so swap one is a
little bit more complicated it builds on
what we did before we just built which
was getting the board implemented and
drawn onto the screen but there's no
behavior at all it's just a static
basically the same thing as drawing an
image onto the screen and so for that
what we want to do is implement swapping
so how do we think we can accomplish
this anybody have any ideas as to how we
can swap
well we could yeah we could for I mean
that'll have the effect of I mean you
assuming the response was we could use
tweening we could and we actually will
for swap too but it's all going to be a
little bit more complicated than that
because they're in a 2d array so if we
just tween they're XY they will be in
the same they will be in the same place
in the array but yes ultimate switch the
position in the array and then reload
the array we will switch the position we
don't have to reload the array but we
can we will switch their positions yep
that's effectively what it is literally
just take two tiles and it's sort of
like swap in cs50 where we just take two
variables and assign get a temp variable
that like points that one variable it
gets its values while the second value
variable gets the values of that one and
then vice versa I think this one gets
this one's values this one gets this
one's values and then this one comes
down to this one basically there's the
middleman that's keep because if this
one gets this one's values it's going to
get overridden by this one's value so
there will be no reference to its XY or
anything so that's why I need to store
this one up here so this one can come
here and this one come back down here so
we've done a swap effectively and
there's ways in Lua to do swaps as we
saw before without even needing a
temporary variable you can just do XY
get some other XY which sort of bypasses
that but when you start to do like for
things getting swapped at once and you
have like four commas it can get a
little tricky a little bit unwieldy I'm
actually not a hundred percent sure you
can unpack more than two things in lua i
have to double check on that but i mean
right off the gate we're seeing that
double assignment here on line 32
highlighted x highlighted y gets 1-1 and
let me actually run just we can see
there's actually a couple of pieces here
besides just that oops one so we have
the board as before we also have
something to like show us where to swap
right because we have to know where
we're swapping the tiles in an ideal
implementation which is an optional part
of the assignment
you would have
you would have Mouse behavior for your
game so you just click on two tiles or
click and drag and swap them in this
case we're not doing that we're just
implementing key bind key based behavior
so I press left right up or down I can
move if I press ENTER on a tile and I
move around it's an indicator to me that
I've selected that tile to swap with
something else because it needs to keep
track of okay you want to swap this tile
what do you want to swap it with I want
to swap it with let's work with this
tile so they get swapped I want to swap
it with this tile so they get swapped or
this tile so you can swap it with that
whatever tile you want to there's no
constraints the actual distro code
implements a constraint and so offhand
what do you think the constraint would
be for making sure that we can yeah yep
they have to be adjacent so what would
that what would that entail exactly and
the shorthand for that really is if the
absolute value of their exes - they're
wise is greater than is a is equal to
one because if you subtract ones ex from
another one's ex and then the ones Y
from another one's Y and then you add
the differences together that'll tell
you whether they're directly adjacent to
each other it has to equal one if it
equals zero then the X's and Y's are the
same if equals 2 then the either it's
like two tiles away on the x-axis or
it's a way on the X and the y in which
case it would be diagonal to it so the
only way is oh it's X's - its X's tywin
X - tile 2 X and tile 1 dot y minus L 2
dot Y if their absolute value of their
difference is 1 then they're Jason
that's in the implementation so yeah so
that's this is why we have these
variables here highlighted tile
basically we're sending a flag saying do
we have a highlighted tile if we do
we're going to perform some like drawing
logic later down in the draw function
it's gonna just draw basically how would
how would we draw a highlighted tile
exactly so the answer was a tit
rectangle with transparency that's
exactly what we do I'm gonna go down to
the this part here so online 173 if we
have a highlighted tile and basically
this is in the middle of it of a loop
though are Y X before we put it into a
draw board we yet we have the jaw board
function but XY or YX tile is going to
be whatever tile we're currently on and
if we do have a highlighted tile and
that tiles grid X notice we now have a
new variable called grid X as opposed to
its regular
X so that we can check for these sorts
of things to see where it is in the
array if it's grid X is equal to
whatever we've set highlighted X 2 and
grid Y is equal to highlighted Y then
set graphics set color love that graphic
so set color half transparency and then
just draw a rectangle with this for at
the end of it which actually draws a
rounded rectangle so you can pass in if
you pass in no for just draw a straight
rectangle but if you pass in an int at
the very end that's how many like
rounded segments basically that
rectangle will have so you get like
rounded corners on your rectangles and
it's good for like in like UI drawing
and stuff like that we use it a little
bit in the distro so that's how you get
a highlighted tile there was also a
selected tile and a selected tile is
just draw a rectangle same thing but
it's a line this time and there's always
gonna be a selected tile no matter what
so we're always gonna draw it here at
the end of our render function
it's just 255 - 34 for the opacity so
that it's just kind of transparent but
not like super transparent set line
width to 4 so that it's not just a very
thin wrecked in rectangle if you set the
line width and then you draw a rectangle
with the line format the line mode of
drawing it will use whatever the current
line width is when in drawing the
rectangle so we said 2 4 then draw a
line rect at selected tile X plus offset
X select a tile dot y plus offset Y and
we draw at 32 by 32 because it's the
size of a tile and let me set our color
remember to always say your color back
to 255 255
255 255 because if you don't and I did
this when I was debugging actually you
get it some fun stuff wait was that the
right one oh I might have fixed it up
above where we there was an issue if you
don't set your basically your color and
you set it to red everything will draw
red after you've done something so if
you had that ever happens remember to
set your color back to 255 255 255 255
at the end of any any time you change
the color in some way like I'm doing
here
yes yeah the the response was make sure
you always set the color before you draw
something I think that's what I ended up
doing in this distros what it's not
working anymore I think it was where was
it it was here but I must have fixed it
because I actually left that out when I
was debugging and then ended up drawing
everything was red so just doesn't aside
just because love 2d is a state machine
but yeah drawing it beforehand is
definitely the safer way to go to back
up to select the core of this because
we're running a little low on time the
core of this overall block of code is
just the swap here so if there's no
highlighted tile so basically if you
press Enter or return and we have all
input handling in love key pressed key
and by the way this is input handling to
like change the X&Y of our selected tile
if we press ENTER and we don't have a
highlighted tile then we need to have a
highlighted tile otherwise we should
swap them so we get a reference to tile
one and two we swap way we create temp
variables recall we need to have that
middleman up here that keeps track of
this tiles information so it's gonna
keep track of all tile twos information
with temp X tempo eye temp grid X and
temp grid Y because we need to not only
change their x coordinates but also
their grid positions and then we need to
create a temp tile here and the
basically here's where we actually swap
their places in the board so tile one
got grid Y Taiwan got grid X gets tile
too and then we're getting a reference
to temp tile so that we can because if
we set board at wherever tile one is too
tile too we won't have anything where
tile two is we need to have like a temp
tile to keep track of tile sorry we
won't have anything at tile one if we
override it with tile two so we need a
reference to tile one here so that we
can put it in to where tile two spot is
right here and then we need to do that
before we actually all that before we
end up swapping their coordinates and
tile grid positions otherwise you get
weird buggy behavior when you're like
moving the selected tile around and then
we can unhighlight and then reset our
selection because their selections also
going to get changed after we do the
swap so we need to put it to the second
tile because it gets swapped with
whatever tile we're highlighted and
that's the that's the overall gist is
this like basically taking two tiles
like flipping their information storing
a middleman same thing in swap in cs50 a
little more complicated though because
these all have like subfields that all
need to get manipulated and this a lot
of this can actually be done
mathematically you can actually have its
grid or its X&Y mathematically derived
from its grid X and grid why I just
multiplied by 32 in this case I just
kept them as variables and separate but
yeah you could just do that too
and that has the effect of swapping the
variables whenever we move them and then
that's the that's the fundamental like
first step in like match three is just
like swapping any two tiles in a given
position so is that like makes sense
altogether okay so the last thing so
this this example is actually very not
that much different at all from swap two
I'm going to show you swap two right now
so if you go to swap two
the only change we really have made is
that now towels like flip tick that
instead of like instantly changing they
tween right and this is a piece of cake
at this point we already know like
what's the function we need to do just
time between we need to do is just take
the two and it's like tween tile 1 X and
tile 1 y 2 tile 2 X and tile to die and
do the same thing in Reverse between
tile 2 x and tile 2 dot y 2 tile 1 X and
tau 1 dot Y and so if we open up swap to
go to main nothing is nothing but in
this program really changes except in
update where we go to line 99 and we're
just doing it here notice the definition
over 0.2 seconds it takes in a
definition table here and it's taking in
two entities we're because we're
modifying two things we're modifying
tile 2 and tile 1 we're just setting X
to tile 1 dot x & y de tile 1 dot y and
then tile ones getting the temp X and
temp Y because before I was just getting
it directly from the temp and now it's
just tweeting it over time but that was
before just a bunch of like tile 2 x
equals tau 1 dot X tile 2 y equals tile
two dot y - I want it white ghost I'll
do that Y that's all it is that's that's
what's really nice about it now we don't
have to really work hard at all to get
like nice smooth transitions and
whatever we do whether it's a UI or the
game it's just super nice and convenient
so that's that's all we need to do to
get basic swapping done that was swap -
between swap and so I put together a set
of slides here just to sort of
illustrate the algorithm that we use to
calculate the matches so right now we've
got swapping in but we don't know when
we've got a match
so just offhand if anybody have any idea
as to maybe how we can go about
calculating whether we've got any
matches
yeah
[Music]
deputy city block you check that colors
who was your color and if he doesn't
check it well then I guess you need to
figure out what the record is in
so the response was maintained so when
you're looking at tiles look at all
adjacent tiles and if there is a color
that's the same one then figure out its
direction and then sort of move from
there sort of like a recursive style I
guess you could implement it recursively
it probably a little bit trickier to
understand and probably not as efficient
the way that we actually going to
implement it is going to be a little bit
more like iterative so what all we
really need to do is check every row and
every column one time and then go
basically left to right so in this case
well we have to check every row and
column one time in this direction and
then one time in this direction because
we can get vertical and horizontal
matches so we go we start off let's just
arbitrarily decide we want to start
going left to right down the down the
data structure so we'll go what color is
this that's brown okay check the next
one is it the same color if it is then
sort of say okay the number of matching
tiles that we've found so far is two if
it's greater than three then later on
we'll need to like add that group as a
match to our to our list of matches
basically but if it's not okay then
number of matches is one again so set it
to one and then do the same thing same
color no okay number of matches is one
in this case here we have number of
matches is going to be 2 because this is
blue and then we're gonna go ahead and
then same color again number of matches
is 3 and then we've gotten to the end of
the row so we can say okay what was our
last number of matches was it greater
than or equal to three if it was add
that group of tiles to our table of
matches we've got a match and then move
on and we do that over and over again
and if it's in the middle of a group
like it is here so this isn't at the end
of the row this is just in the middle of
the row what we do is number of matches
one two three and then
we go here and it's set to one or well
first of all we check number of matches
when we get to a different color we say
ok this isn't the same color as this
tile this is purple this is green this
is gray but number of matches is three
so what we do is we just add these three
tiles to our we keeping a like a table
of matches because we're going to go
through and we're gonna delete all of
them and then eventually we're going to
do some tweening as well but we're gonna
delete all of these and then in order to
do that we need to walk backwards right
we need to say add basically four X gets
position minus number of tiles in the
match just like add that to a match add
that to a match add that to a match and
add the match to our table of matches
that's it for they like the x-direction
and for the y directions the exact same
thing going down here different color
different color a different color a
different color and then same color same
color different color but number of
matches is three right because one two
three and then it's going to walk
backwards up to the top add that match
and then just continue down here same
thing same thing and then same thing
there this is at the end of the column
so it's going to get to the end it's not
actually going to look for the next tile
because there are no more tiles but
every time we complete a row or a column
we check at the very end do we have the
number of matches equal to three or
greater if we do then we need to do the
same logic as we did before by adding
that match to our list of matches so
it's actually quite a simple algorithm
and this is sort of like the set of
steps that is illustrated you know we
have match found there oak sorry Tony
yes
it would if you complete the question
was if you complete two matches at once
will it see both yes if you complete and
it wouldn't if you deleted them as you
went because you know if you let's say
you had like one two three here I'm
assuming this what you mean like one two
three one two three if if you just
deleted them as you went then no I
wouldn't see them it would go here and
would get these three delete them and
then it would to see these two but
because we walk over the entire thing
and then we only delete matches after
all of the matches have processed we're
gonna add this one first and then when
we do our vertical one we're also going
to see this one and so it's gonna count
as two matches and you could make your
code a little bit more complicated if
you wanted to and say if there's an
intersection between two matches I want
to give the player more points or I want
to give him some sort of effect like in
candy crush I think you'd get like
explosions or bejeweled you get
explosions if you get like a like a t
pattern and if you get four in a row you
get like a like a laser or something
going across the screen like that's
actually part of the assignment is like
clear a row if you get four in a row you
should clear that row or call them if
you you know if you do that then yeah
you can have logic but currently the
distro all the distro does is just the
simple iteration horizontally then
vertically and adding matches as you go
and actually there's an optimization
that you can make if you go here like
for example let's say we're going here
here and then we're here and we're at a
different color than the last one we can
just like go to the next one we can just
skip because we know we only have two
left right there's no point looking for
a match if you're at the end - - because
there's no possible way to get a match
so that's just a shortcut a little
optimization you can make and that's
actually in the code just break off if
you're at in the code it's x or y equals
seven just go to the next just break out
of that for loop basically and go to the
next row or column
yeah any more questions as to sort of
how that works that's in the if you're
actually looking in the code we won't go
over it in too much detail in class it's
fairly straightforward I think once I
walk you through the algorithm a little
bit but I'll point you to the lines
they're relevant lines it's in the place
state and I'm sorry it's in the board in
the calculate matches function here on
line 50 calculate matches so horizontal
matches y gets one to eight it's looking
you could keep a color to match and
basically you just keep track of how
many you've matched match numbers one
always when you're doing a brand new
color and then starting at X 2 to 8
because we already got the first tile
basically if the color is the same
increment match num otherwise that our
current color to that color the next
tile if we've done this and our match is
greater than or equal to three then we
found a match we can add a match we
create a new table we go backwards from
where we are with X to gets X minus 1
and then X minus match num so it works
for no matter how long the match is
whether it's three four or five and then
we're subtracting one and then you just
insert a into that match the tile at
that x2 position because the matches are
made up tiles so a match is just like a
group of tiles put together and so you
can intersect to any given match just
buy it comparing the tiles and just
seeing if they have the same tiles
basically that's how you'd get like a
five like a cross match and then after
that's all done just insert into matches
that match here's the little
optimization if X is greater than equal
to seven and this is in part of the loop
where we've we already know that we're
on a new color from the last color which
is a break and then set matching them to
one if we haven't gotten to that point
yet and then this is the part of the
code that sort of accounts for a last
row like the the row ending with a match
because we are not going to be on the
next loop to like see whether we're
going to a different color we just need
to check to make sure
at the end of any row iteration or
column iteration when we go to the next
row or column before we go the next row
or column that match row match num is
greater than equal to three and if so
then do the same logic here but start
exit eight and same thing for vertical
matches is actually exact same logic
just x and y are inverted and then
that's it and then self dot matches we
keep a reference to self dot matches in
the board so that later we can like
remove them here and then I believe we
use it for something else and then
number and then we return basically if
the number of matches is greater than
zero we're gonna return matches else
we're just gonna set we're just gonna
return false and we can use this later
we can say if matches from our place
date then like we can call a few other
functions and like bring in new tiles
and stuff like that but just for the
sake of being thorough
as an illustration this is sort of like
how the algorithm works in this case
actually this is before I made the
optimization we wouldn't actually do
this in this particular case this would
this would have short-circuited down to
the next column before it even checked
this but if your algorithm didn't make
that optimization then the I would just
see two tiles there go the next one
nothing there no matches
same thing here there is a match there
and the match would be found not at the
end of the diagram here like it would
actually be found it would be calculated
when like it's pointed here but it knows
match three match num is greater than or
equal to three at that point and it does
the exact same thing here we just go
column wise and then nothing there
nothing there and then we got one right
there and so the next part Oh
any questions on like how that works at
all
cool the the next part I mean we have
the matches now we have them in tables
we have the tiles we have references to
the tiles like how do we remove the
tiles once we have once we like how do
we get rid of them as soon as we have
the matches so I mean that we have
assuming that our board is a table the
2-d table and each array within there
just has a tile object how would we sort
of clear the board of our tiles no just
just just remove just remove it from
just like remove like that just remove
it from play yeah you know yeah you
could yeah with a little bit of
finagling you could get it to where you
could like set up tile to be like
invisible and then you could just like
give it a new tile IID I guess and then
like shift it up above and then like
sort of make it come well it sort of
gets oh I don't know if that approach
necessarily works super well for this
because I like gravity because the tiles
have to come down so then you have to
like sort of like bring the lower ones
if they were like the bottom here like
those would have to like kind of come
down it's it's a little bit that that
kind of approach would be a little
tricky you can make it work I think but
the simple the simple approach which we
used in the this distro is actually just
setting them to nil because if you set
something to no it's just not going to
render in this case so we're just
sending all these tiles that were
previously there to nil there there
nothing at this point they effectively
would render like this if you try to
render them assuming that your code
accounted for it or didn't break and
then the next stage would be like the
actual like getting the board fixed
right because we have the tiles removed
like so now we have this this thing here
but there is a step that has to happen
before we get new tiles and that's
gravity right like we have to actually
shift everything down so how how do we
go about shifting like tiles down
so like this first column we don't
really have to do anything right like
this columns all set but like what about
this column how would we shift how would
we get that tile to like go down sorry
twins yes we could do it with twins but
from a like data structure standpoint
like how would we yet because that will
just tween the XY but that won't
necessarily think like the underlying
data structure still has to represent
what cuz we're gonna do iterations over
it we still have to have references to
the tiles and the right spots yeah so
like how would you like start by getting
this tile down to like this position you
would but how would you how would your
algorithm work step by step to like
making sure that that would happen
exactly exactly that's exactly we do so
if it's you start from the bottom and
then whenever we have anything that's
nil we need to look for the first tile
above it that's not nil and shifted down
so in this case we're star from the
bottom we go
up this way we like not nil not nil not
nil not nil not know so none of those
are spaces in the code there it's called
space Y or space and space Y so we go to
the next column over and we only have to
check hora vertically in this case we
don't have to do a horizontal check for
anything because gravity can only fall
in one direction so we just go over here
so we're only looping through this code
effectively in this case five times but
and our code eight times but it needs to
be a while loop rather than a for loop
and we'll see why in a second but start
here oh we see oh we have a space there
so we need to do is like say okay the
lowest space is here so we need to look
for the next tile above it and shift it
down so we keep a reference to this and
we look up here and we say oh this is a
tile perfect so I'm just gonna take this
tile and I'm gonna set that space index
to that tile and then I'm gonna set this
index to nil and then we just have to
start again though
from here because if this this tiles no
space right so we have to look up here
and say okay so our basically our Y
counter stays at that thing and just
goes back up because there our Y counter
could theoretically come all the way up
here before it finds a tile and then
shift it all the way down but we can't
just or here let's say let's say there
are two tiles right here we our Y
counter might end up here because these
are all spaces and the tile gets shifted
down here but we can't just start our Y
counter back here again and go up to the
next tile then look for spaces because
we have all these spaces down here so
it's a while loop so while basically
there are no spaces on any of these
points we need to make sure that we keep
lowering the tile so keep reference here
tile here bring it down space here so we
keep a reference to space we say oh
there's a space here now we can't look
all the way up but there's no tiles
anywhere so we know that we can just
move on to the next iteration of the
loop we haven't found any tiles we won't
need to bother with it same thing here
we have a space reference here tile
found a tile shift it down space here
tile here shifted down space here tile
here shifted down space space
done and then we rinse and repeat that
it's kind of almost like a bubble sort
some type of algorithm not like not a
sort but it sort of has the same sort of
look and behavior to it more or less we
like here's it just a visual sort of
illustration of it so star from the
bottom go up we're looking for spaces
here no spaces column is perfectly
stable we found a space here tiles there
shift it down restart the loop from the
tile space space space no more spaces
calm stable space found tile found shift
space found tile found shift space found
tile found shift and so on and so forth
and so that's the gist super super basic
but now we actually have to replace the
tiles right we've you
yeah actually that's true yeah I guess
in that case you wouldn't need to but we
do need a reference to that space and
like keep checking above it so but yeah
I guess you you probably don't need
necessarily to check whether it's a
space or not you can just assume it's a
space and I actually think my code does
that I'm not 100% sure off the top of my
head we can check and see it's in I
think it's down here
no is it calculate notice and get
following tiles I think which is on line
177 so 4 1 2 8 and X we keep a space Y
so space Y we said 2 0 that's just like
a variable like we don't have a space
yet so just because you can't index a
tile or index you can index Lua tables
by zero but because they're not by
default we're just setting a zero it's
kind of like our sense it like our false
space flag Y gets 8 starting at the
bottom so while Y is greater than equal
to 1 tile gets self that tiles Y at X in
that case it's gonna be at the 8th
position if space so space is set to
false but space is our is our space
found flag so and also whether or not
the tile that we just looked at was a
space or sorry no it's just just our
space flag we check to see if there's a
tile at our current position so recall
everything gets set to nil so we can
just say local tile get stuff that tiles
Y X this will be nil if there was no
tile there so if tile which means if
it's not nil if it equals something
space Y of X is going to equal that tile
so whatever we keep a reference to space
Y which is our last space we set tile
grid Y to space Y because we have to
reset its grid why we're going to tween
it here this is how we actually get like
the falling tweening behavior like we're
gonna tween its y2
you titled at grid y -1 times 30 to
recall because luke has coordinates are
zero based but lua tables are 1 indexed
space is false
why is space y and then space y gets 0
so yeah so we're gonna start basically
we're gonna start at the we're going to
put space Y to that tile and then we're
going to set space Y to 0 I think it
actually does in this case it is
actually checking that tile to make sure
that it's yeah because it's just getting
set to the tile a the space Y being the
tile that we just replaced and just put
into an actual spot so it does actually
make the check up above to see whether
that's a space or not only one caveat
though actually is no actually no that
wouldn't be true yeah I was gonna say if
we're at the top of the screen but no
because there's no way we can be at the
top of the screen and have yeah I don't
think it would work
so yeah optimization some optimization
you could make is yeah just assume
always a space yeah but yeah that's and
that's the falling that's the like get
falling tiles in a nutshell or at least
the the ones that are falling from
gravity and then we also have tiles that
we want to add to replace them and so
we'll see that here so this code so what
we need to do to replace just like what
you guys think we need to do to to get
replacement tiles
yeah exactly so the response was check
to see if from the top if there are any
tiles that are empty and if there are
then spawn some tiles and then ideally
tween them to the new positions you can
basically just assign them to their
values here so what we need to do
actually though is if we spawn a tile up
here to put into any of these positions
like their their grid wise need to be
sort of set in advance because they're
gonna like occupy that space anyway
their actual Y position needs to be
twinned so because the X and the y are
separate from the grid Y and the grid X
those are just like table indices but
not their coordinates we can tween those
and no one actually have any effect on
the data structure the data structure
itself can maintain we can still use the
data structure like put a tile in this
right spot in our table and then give it
the right grid X and grid Y but between
the Y value the X&Y value those we can
we can do whatever we want with those we
can make them like spin around and stuff
as long as the data structure is intact
and ideally as long as we can't like
input while it's doing like its movement
and stuff like that because I could
create some visual bugs and so what we
do is we actually disable input when a
swap is taking place and you'll see that
in the distribution code but yes count
how many spaces there are spawn for
tiles spawn two tiles spawn two tiles
spawn for tiles that have already been
given there right grid X grid Y and then
just tween there Y to the wherever it
needs to go its grid grid Y times 32
good y -1 times 32 and so that's what
we're doing here is count and then OOP
that's my favorite part putting this
side show together
and so we're gonna get into a couple
minutes of talking about sprites and
palettes but I think the one thing I
blanking for a second I was going to
talk about one last thing let me see if
I can figure out what that was oh right
if we so in the board sorry in the play
state I believe is where this is there
is a function so play state has its own
calculate matches basically where it
waits for you to where once you've
basically swapped any two tiles it'll
calculate whether those tiles haven't
made a match and we're gonna get matches
via self board calculate matches the
function that we were looking at before
if there are any matches well we play a
sound effect here for every match this
is where you also calculate the score
you just multiply the number of tiles in
the match by 50 if part of the
assignment will be adding some value to
like the individual varieties of the
tiles here we tween so we we return also
from the board class a table of tweens
for all of the new tiles that we just
spawned and so what we're gonna end up
doing is tweening all of them here so
notice that we we're passing in a timer
between this variable tiles to fall
that's the definition file that we're
just returning from our board class and
so once those are all finished then we
get new tiles and then we Twain here I
think this is I think this line is
redundant actually I think this might
have been a debugging line I don't think
we need this no we don't need this at
all so sorry this is the important part
we're going to between oh wait we do
need it so if I get bored get new tiles
what am I
thinking uh there's the affection in
case I get new tiles get falling tiles
sorry a little bit confused for a second
I thought this was an empty function
that I defined get new tiles
yeah just returns an empty table so but
basically the gist of it is the play
state when it calls this function it
will like call itself every time and I
think this is actually having the result
of doing it instantly here because new
tiles just an empty table I think this
all this should be is just this inside
like all of this like that but that has
the result of calling itself again
because when we get new tiles coming
from the top of the screen we could
potentially have a case where you know
we've gotten some matches and it's not
showing here but like new match new
falling tiles could give us new matches
so after we calculate matches like let's
say maybe this tile dropped here but it
was a purple and these two were already
there like we've already calculated
matches but then we need to like do it
again and then do it again if it keeps
happening and so just we recursively
call self calculate matches in that case
which will have the effect of
accomplishing that because this will
always look for matches and so when we
call self calculate matches here over
and over again until there are no
matches like as long as there are
matches this should keep keep happening
you should keep getting scores and tiles
should keep getting cleared but as soon
as that's not the case anymore then self
dot can input equals true and we're not
calculating matches anymore we don't
recursively call the function anymore
and we're done and so that's just the
point I wanted to illustrate got
slightly confused by I think what was a
vestige of my old code maybe I was
trying something but I think this
ultimately should just be this and I'll
test it and make sure and then push the
change but yeah we just need to recurs
and it doesn't need to be over 0.25
seconds it can just be instant but
that's that pallets really quickly was
something I wanted to cover which was
just the idea of taking art and then
just and have a couple cool examples to
show just taking some sort of picture
and then giving it only
using or some sort of image and only
using 32 in this case or some arbitrary
number of colors this is some like fancy
stuff that some person named Don bringer
online did he generated a very famous 32
color palette called Don bringers 32
color palette but basically it allows
these this is done with just 32 colors
where you see on the screen those are
all did dithering is a term which means
to just write like draw two colors pixel
by pixel interleaved so that from far
away it looks like a brand new color and
this is a dithering chart this just
shows you every color here at the very
top these are all 32 colors these 32 and
those are 32 intersected with each other
so such that they're just like dot dot
dot dot dot like inter like every other
dot is every other color and so you can
do some pretty amazing things with just
a few colors this is actually done with
16 colors all four of those are only 16
colors this is a just to show you what
it looks like when you do it to an
actual image this is this is an example
of what like using a color palette on an
image that doesn't work well with it
looks like so this is a regular image
with I don't know how many colors
thousands and millions of colors and
this is using dumb bring your study to
color palette so still looks very
similar to what it should it's a cat but
there's a lot of weird things going on
in the background because taking an
image with a lot of blur and a lot of
like distorted color sort of has the
effect of giving you blotchy patterns
when you go down to a few colors but
this is an example of an image that has
a lot of like flatter colors there's
still a lot of colors in this image
there's some shades and stuff like that
but this is like thousands of colors and
this has 32 colors so like clearly if
you do it on the right thing you can
actually get really good effects with it
and so you know again not a whole lot of
difference but this one's got I don't
know how many hundreds or thousands of
colors and so only got 32 and so how it
ties back into what we're doing is this
is a this is using a 32-bit color or 32
color palette on purpose this is
actually Dom bring your 32 color palette
break out used a the same palette 32
colors and future a lot of our 2d future
lectures will use limited color palettes
if you're trying to draw sprite art and
you want some quick and easy ways just
to give your work a little bit of
consistency I recommend just sort of
like trying to pick 8 or 16 or 32 colors
and just adhering to using just those
and you'd be surprised at like how much
you get out of it and how more cooking
much more cohesive your work will look
just by sort of like imposing that
constraint on you it's a it's a artifact
of a real world constraint of former
hardware like the NES only had so many
colors that could color each sprite like
4 colors or something like that and so
you'll also get a if you're going for
like a authentic retro look it'll help
you in that sense and then different
from palettes but related is palette
swapping which is another term you've
probably heard which is basically all of
these Mario sprites late like assume
they start I mean they'll probably start
with a grayscale Mario some like gray
version where each of these separate
colors are mapped out to some like table
where one equals red two equals blue or
whatever and then you can just shift all
of them and then you get all these
different nice effects assuming that
you've you know created a palette a good
palette you can get a lot of reuse and
this is actually how Super Mario
Brothers used to do some of its
programming the clouds and the bushes
were the same sprite one was just
colored green it was palette swapped
green from the white that the cloud was
colored so that's that's the gist of
match-three assignment three is gonna
have a few parts to it so time addition
on matches so when you get a match you
should get time added to the clock
currently right now you only get 60
seconds it's a little bit hard to
actually get past level 2 at this point
so getting points for every tile in a
match make it so that level 1 starts
with simple flat blocks so earlier we
saw the array of tiles and it was flat
tiles on the first index of every color
row but there are several other patterns
like X's and circles and triangles and
stuff make those worth a sum higher
amount of value
each one create random shiny variants of
blocks that will destroy an entire row
when you get a match so have a block
should have some field shiny or
something if it's shiny render it with
some thing to make it look shiny you can
use particle effect if you want you can
use a you can put just like a like a
very opaque or a very transparent maybe
yellowish or whitish rectangle on it to
give it a sort of a brighter look and
then just if it's in a match the entire
row should get cleared instead of just
that match swap only allows swapping
when it results in a match so this is an
important thing because right now
mathematically it's actually very
unlikely that you'll get a board that
has matches on it to begin with so
you're gonna have to pick a subset of
tiles in the in your implementation and
actually use those in instead of just
using all of them like pick six tiles
which you can get variants on or just
whatever flat colors and then you use
only those to spawn your board don't use
all eighteen or however many there are
and then optional if you got if you're
curious if you want probably a arguably
better gaming experience with this just
implement actually playing with the
mouse like being able to click and drag
or just click individual tiles and to do
that you will need to convert because we
use the push library for virtual
resolution you need to convert the game
the window Mouse coordinates to push
coordinates so that they'll map into the
game space appropriately and so you'll
use a function called push to game or
take some X&Y where the X and the y will
be your mouse coordinates next time
we're actually going to get into a
little bit more robust of a game
arguably like a Mario clone this is
actually sort of where this game start
or this course started was I taught a
seminar on Super Mario Brothers we won't
be using Super Mario Brothers assets
because of copyright but we'll be using
this tiles cheat here which is very
similar it's got a nice aesthetic will
cover tile maps so how to generate
levels using individual tiles 2d
animation so rather than just like
static things that we've had going on so
far you'll have characters that actually
walk and jump and do different things
we'll talk about how to actually proceed
you generate platformer levels
which isn't terribly difficult it sounds
kind of difficult but it's actually
pretty it furred like very simple stuff
it's not too bad
basic platformer physics so hitting
blocks and then like jumping and stuff
like that we've covered a lot of that
with flappy bird actually so that'll be
and actually the bricks from breakout
kind of tie into it a little bit hurt
boxes so we can have enemies that hurt
you and vice versa and power-ups so that
you can change your state in some way to
make you larger or invincible or whatnot
but that was match-three thanks a lot
and see you next time